[Musik]
hey schön dass ihr dabei sein zdf heute
live viele von uns kennen aktuell jemand
oder der die gerade in quarantäne es in
corona quarantäne denn die zahlen sind
immer noch hoch aber zum wochenende
fallen die meisten maßnahmen weg und das
ist heute bei uns thema denn ab montag
zum beispiel ist shoppen ohne maske in
vielen bundesländern wieder erlaubt das
sieht fast ein bisschen so aus als würde
die politik sagen die pandemie die ist
jetzt für beendet oder erklärt sie für
beendet bislang gibt es nur zwei
bundesländer mecklenburg vorpommern und
seit heute ist auch klar hamburg die die
sogenannte hot spot regel nutzen wollen
das bedeutet ganz knapp test und masken
pflicht werden beibehalten und ob die
länder das einfach so können ob da aber
auch klagen kommen das ist heute bei uns
thema wir können darüber reden und eure
fragen und kommentare dazu jederzeit per
mail oder direkt im stream ihr blenden
euch auch hier die mailadresse nochmal
ein und wir können darüber mit zwei
experten sprechen einmal hier bei uns im
studio ist rechtsexperte vom zdf
christian decker und dann uns noch
zugeschaltet dialoge martin stürmer er
lehrt an der universität frankfurt
schönen guten abend ihr beiden hallo
und herrscht immer noch wunderbar sie
können uns auch gut hören und damit wir
alle auf dem gleichen stand sind schauen
wir zuerst einmal in einen beitrag von
meiner kollegin julia schröter sie hat
die regeln und den status quo der für
uns alle dann gilt ab nächster woche mal
zusammengefasst
ab kommenden sonntag fallen die meisten
coroner regeln in deutschland weg in
vielen bereichen etwa beim einkaufen im
supermarkt gilt dann keine masken
pflicht mehr
zugangsregelungen wie 2g oder 3g
beispielsweise im restaurant sind dann
ebenfalls geschichte so steht es im
neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz und so handhaben
ist die allermeisten bundesländer von
nord nach süd und west nach ost quer
durch die republik ausnahme mecklenburg
vorpommern und hamburg lockern erstmal
nicht sie machen von der hotspot
regelung gebraucht die eintritt wenn der
landtag eine kritische lage fest stellt
das heißt abstandsregeln gelten weiter
auch masken pflicht in innenräumen und
zugangsbeschränkungen bleiben in den
beiden bundesländern vorerst bestehen
bis ende april nur in thüringen ist noch
unklar wie es weitergeht dort steht eine
entscheidung noch aus
herr stürmer direkt erstmal jetzt am
anfang die frage an sie weil es ist ja
schon kurios die zahlen sind hoch die
maßnahmen fallen aber weg was heißt das
für uns alle heißt dass jetzt die
pandemie ist tatsächlich für sowas wie
beendet erklärt oder wie lässt sich das
einschätzen
natürlich ist die pandemie nicht vorbei
es ist so dass wir in einer situation
uns befinden wo das infektionsgeschehen
ja doch relativ hoch ist wir sind mitten
in einer welle von baa2 infektion das
ist dieser omikron subtyp der sich noch
mal sehr effizient verbreitet und ja man
muss halt schauen ob das ganze jetzt
tatsächlich schon die situation ist die
wir uns alle wünschen dass wir zur
normalität zurückkehren dass wir lernen
können mit diesem virus schon zu leben
und ich bin der meinung dass wir das
noch nicht können insofern sind für mich
diese lockerung jetzt definitiv zu früh
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass wir da noch
vier bis sechs wochen warten und ich
glaube dann kann man ganz anders
argumentieren aber zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt sich die pandemie noch längst
nicht beendet
schauen wir vielleicht auch mal ganz
kurz auf eine kleine karte die ich euch
hier auf meinem laptop hoffentlich
zeigen kann bei uns auf der zdf heute
seite sieht man zum beispiel jetzt ganz
aktuell ein bisschen hoch scrollen der
anteil der positiven pcr test in
deutschland aktuell sehen wir also
relativ hoch und wie ich schon
angesprochen habe es ist ja auch
tatsächlich so viele von uns kennen ja
auch jemand der oder die gerade
infiziert ist aber es ist ja spannend
wir kommen zurück zu dem thema auch mit
den sogenannten hotspot regelungen das
was hamburg und schleswig-holstein
mecklenburg-vorpommern entschuldigung
dass die ihr auch nutzen möchten und
darüber können wir jetzt mal sprechen
mit christian decker denn die definition
was so ein hotspot ist und wohl genau
gilt ich glaube das müssen wir erst mal
ein bisschen besprechen ist das denn
ganz klar und eindeutig oder wie ist da
die lage also geregelt ist das im
infektionsschutzgesetz das ist ein
bundesgesetz das der bundestag
verabschiedet hat das heißt diese
grundsätzlichen regeln gelten erst mal
für alle bundesländer und dort ist im
vorgegeben dass für sogenannte
gebietskörperschaften eben festgestellt
werden kann dass hier der bedarf steht
besteht noch mal strengere regeln
fortzuführen weiterzuführen und es gibt
zwei fälle in denen eine solche hotspot
regelung verhängt werden darf der eine
fall ist wenn das eine wie russland
variante mit einer signifikant höheren
pathogenität also
krankheitserreger wenn die stärker sind
als bisher dass der gesetzesbegründung
steht hier das es zum beispiel bei einer
neuen variante oder bei einer rückkehr
der delta variante denkbar wäre das ist
der eine fall der in frage kommt und der
andere fall ist wenn eine überlastung
des gesundheitssystem droht wenn die
krankenhäuser überlastet werden können
es gibt aber hier in diesen regelungen
wenn man sich ins gesetz wenn man ins
gesetz reinschaut gibt es relativ viele
begriffe die nicht definiert sind also
zum beispiel was heißt
gebietskörperschaft ist dass ein ganzes
bundesland oder ist das nur ein
landkreis anderes beispiel was heißt
überlastung der krankenhäuser also
überlastung ist ein sehr dehnbarer
begriff da kann man sehr vieles darunter
verstehen wo beginnt das wo ende des dh
das infektionsschutzgesetz gibt an
dieser stelle keine zumindest keine
klaren kriterien oder keine
schwellenwerte wo man sagen kann ab hier
ist eine hotspot regelungen
gerechtfertigt und er stellt für die
bundesländer natürlich für vor größere
probleme
wir sprechen auch gleich noch mal mehr
und eingehender über das gesetz aber du
hast doch gerade was angesprochen das
finde ich spannend denn es ist auch so
dass schleswig-holstein beispielsweise
heute nämlich auch vermeldet hatte sie
haben wohl weil es so viele corona
infektionen gibt sorge um die kritische
infrastruktur in einigen teilen im
bundesland also das bedeutete dann das
personal in krankenhäusern oder bei
polizei wegen corona ausfällt und man
eben natürlich schauen muss wie der
betrieb aufrecht gehalten wird der
stürmer das ist natürlich jetzt auch
eine situation also wie kann man das
einschätzen es sind natürlich auch
einige menschen jetzt geimpft es sind
auch einige chinesen die dann dazu
kommen ist die situation jetzt also
genauso dramatisch ähnlich dramatisch
wie wir es im winter hatten oder ist
jedoch anders das müssten sie uns bitte
noch mal
nein natürlich ist es so je mehr
menschen geimpft sind je mehr menschen
die infektion hinter sich haben die sind
natürlich erstmal in der frühphase nicht
unbedingt wieder mit der gleich wieder
zu infizieren wird das virus also wenn
ich jetzt gerade micon durch habe ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit noch mal auch
mitkommen zu bekommen relativ gering
auch wenn es zwei unterschiedliche
varianten sind nichtsdestotrotz sehe ja
anhand der hohen fallzahlen
das ist eben noch nicht das ende der
fahnenstange ist dass ihm immer noch
genug menschen gibt die sich infizieren
und wir dürfen nicht vergessen viele
menschen bei denen liegt die booster
impfung ja auch schon wieder ein paar
wochen bis monate zurück und auch die
werden sich wieder gehäuft anstecken
können und das risiko geht man eben
damit ein wenn wir eben
infektionsgeschehen weiter auf diesem
hohen level lassen dass wir eben
insgesamt viele menschen sich infizieren
lassen und was mir bei omikron auch
auffällt und auch aus vielen gerichten
von leuten die sich infiziert haben die
berichten über eine deutlich stärkere
symptomatik ohne dass sie in die
krankenhäuser müssen aber ich denke dass
einfach die ausfallquote von infizierten
hier noch mal eine rolle spielen wird
die uns so ein bisschen probleme machen
weil selbst wenn wir nicht so viele
menschen in die krankenhäuser bekommen
müssen wir doch viele menschen zu hause
lassen weil sie sich eben auch wirklich
sehr sehr schlapp und unwohl fühlen und
nicht arbeitsfähig sind und das darf man
nicht unterschätzen und dementsprechend
sollte man meiner meinung nach deutlich
vorsichtiger sein und nicht zu
leichtfertig das ganze so ein bisschen
abbügeln ist das dann auch ihre antwort
an kritik die zum beispiel von einem ich
sag mal kollegen von ihnen kommt von
jonas schmidt-chanasit der hatte nämlich
gesagt dass er hart kritisiert im
prinzip er frage sich auf welcher
grundlage der wissenschaftlichen daten
man eben maßnahmen corona maßnahmen
sonst aufrechterhalten aufrechterhalten
möchte er sagte nämlich zitat inzwischen
haben also millionen von menschen die
infektion mit verschiedenen corona
virusvarianten durchgemacht und sind
genesen das muss man bei den maßnahmen
natürlich berücksichtigen was wäre ihre
antwort darauf
hierbei müssen uns immer überlegen
welche welche ziele wir setzen wir haben
ja als primäres ziel die die überlastung
des gesundheitssystems aus offen wir
sehen das durchaus in den krankenhäusern
keine entspannte situation herrscht
sondern aufgrund eben der hohen
fallzahlen im trotzdem probleme
auftauchen und diese tatsache muss man
berücksichtigen dass ist ja unabhängig
davon wie viele menschen die infektion
durchgemacht haben wir müssen spätestens
im herbst damit rechnen dass uns noch
mal eine welle ereilt und alle die die
infektion jetzt durchgemacht haben sind
dann nicht mehr adäquat geschützt also
insofern ist das immer in der relation
zu sehen wie lange die infektion jetzt
tatsächlich zurückliegt und selbst wenn
ich ein paar durchläufe schon mit
unterschiedlichen varianten gehabt habe
heißt es noch lange nicht dass ich gegen
eine möglicherweise noch einmal neu
kommen der variante wieder komplett
geschützt bin natürlich werden wir
solche sachen berücksichtigen müssen in
einer gewissen form aber sicherlich
nicht meiner meinung nach nicht in dem
umfang dass wir jetzt komplett alle
maßnahmen fallen lassen können ich
glaube der zeitpunkt ist noch nicht
gekommen
sprechen wir noch einmal auch über das
was uns aber jetzt dann bevorsteht weil
es wird ja so passieren wahrscheinlich
also in vielen bundesländern werden die
maßnahmen fallen ich möchte auch kurz
die stimmung bei uns im stream dazu mal
wieder geben was sie bei youtube
schreibt ich bin froh dass es bei uns in
hessen keine hotspot regelung gibt und
nordfriesland liebe bei youtube schreibt
bei uns in rheinland pfalz ist alles
aufgehoben gott sei dank wer will soll
maske tragen aber lassen sie uns lasst
uns gemeinsam jetzt auch noch mal auf
die hotspot regelung schauen und dann
auch noch mal mit dir das einordnen
christian der bundesgesundheitsminister
lauterbach hatte heute das habe ich auch
gelesen ich würde auch gerne noch mal
zitieren sich geäußert also zu dieser
hotspot regelung und er sagte man mag
das gesetz mögen oder nicht aber es ist
juristisch sauber gemacht so dass es
umsetzbar wäre aus den ländern hört man
da aber kritik und was ganz anderes was
sagst du dazu
ich glaube dass man da tatsächlich
geteilter meinung sein kann also auf der
einen seite ist ebenso dass wir
verfassungsrechtlich in den letzten zwei
jahren sehr tiefgreifende einschnitte
eingriffe in unsere grundrechte hatten
wenn man an die ausgangssperre und so
weiter zum beispiel denkt und klar ist
dass wenn die krone situation sich
verbessert und wenn die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems nicht mehr so
akut droht dass dann diese eingriffe in
die grundfreiheiten einfach aus
rechtlichen gründen zurückgefahren
werden müssen so argumentiert ja auch
zum beispiel der bundesjustizminister
marco buschmann von der fdp das ist die
eine seite die andere seite ist aber
natürlich die wie das gesetz konkret
gemacht ist und da ist das thema
rechtssicherheit ein ganz großes thema
weil die 16 bundesländer sind darauf
angewiesen dass die regeln die sie jetzt
in kraft setzen also zum beispiel
hamburg und mecklenburg vorpommern die
beide sich entschieden haben die hotspot
regelung für das ganze bundesland in
kraft zu setzen dass die natürlich
gefahr laufen dass gerichte diese
entscheidung am ende kassieren wenn sie
nämlich den rechtlichen vorgaben nicht
entsprechen also wenn sie sich nicht an
das gesetz halten wenn die kriterien des
gesetzes nicht eingehalten werden und da
das gesetz eben da einen sehr großen
einschätzungsspielraum lässt es ist sehr
schwer vorherzusagen wie die
gerichtlichen entscheidung am ende
tatsächlich ausgehen werden wir haben so
eine kritische stimme aber auch aus den
ländern vorliegen und zwar den
bayerischen gesundheitsminister
holetschek und was er da genau
kritisiert da wollen wir mal kurz
zusammen reinhören
ich hoffe der ton ist der parameter die
vorgegeben sind sind viel zu unbestimmt
um rechtssicher tatsächlich einen
hotspot auszulösen und andere länder
sehen das ja übrigens genauso schauen
sie nach baden württemberg wo die grünen
an der regierung sind oder in hessen
auch dort wird ganz klar ein in einer
großen einigkeit gesagt dieses gesetz
ist untauglich es ist geprägt von einer
ideologie der fdp dem wunsch nach einem
freedom day aber nicht dem wunsch nach
dem schutz der gesundheit der
bevölkerung
er nennt das gesetz untauglich
vielleicht sind wir da aber noch mal
ganz genau und sagen zumindest mal was
die kritischen unklaren punkte sind also
der hauptpunkt der glaube ich sehr
kritisch ist ist unter welchen
voraussetzungen kann ich einen hotspot
ausrufen das ist einfach völlig unklar
und wenn man sich umhört bei den
regierungen in den bundesländern daher
statt zum teil wirklich schulterzucken
und große ratlosigkeit
darf ich jetzt ein hotspot auf ausrufen
ja oder nein und was sind die konkreten
stellen also
es geht ja letztlich auch zum beispiel
und prognostische entscheidungen also
ich muss ja ein hotspot ausrufen bevor
die überlastung des gesundheitssystems
da ist und wie kann ich das vorhersehen
und wann ist der richtige zeitpunkt
gekommen das ist ganz schwierig zu
entscheiden und diese politischen
entscheidungen unterliegen immer einer
rechtlichen kontrolle ist gibt immer
gerichte die bei klagen das überprüfen
werden und da kann ich die
landesregierung schon ein stück weit
verstehen dass sie sagen es ist für uns
eine enorm schwierige entscheidung jetzt
gerade wie wir uns verhalten wollen was
ich hier lese gerade bei uns im stream
von richard allawi habermeier er
schreibt man kann ja zum selbstschutz
die maske weiterhin tragen appellierte
also ein bisschen an die
eigenverantwortung von uns ein der
stürmer wie schätzen sie das ein
trautmann vielleicht aber auch bislang
den deutschen bürgerinnen und bürgern
dazu wenig eigenverantwortung zu
ja das thema eigenverantwortung ist ja
ist ja nicht neu in dieser pandemie das
ist ja schon mehrfach an die
eigenverantwortung appelliert worden mit
der bitte entsprechend zu agieren und es
hat ja eigentlich nie so richtig
funktioniert und das liegt nicht daran
dass sich das gros der menschen nicht
dran hält ich traue es den meisten
menschen zu und ich weiß auch dass sie
das tun dass viele der rücksicht darauf
nehmen aber das problem ist dass zum
beispiel die masken im inneren dann ihre
effizienz zeigen wenn alle beteiligten
die maske tragen lassen sie zehn prozent
in einem supermarkt der voll ist die
maske nicht tragen das wären dann
vielleicht auch die zehn prozent sein
die am ehesten dann auch die infektionen
dabei haben und dann hat man ein problem
und das ist das ganze und mir geht es ja
gar nicht darum so stringent über das
ganze jahr hinweg an diesen maßnahmen
festzuhalten mir geht es im prinzip
darum dass wir hier vier bis sechs
wochen nur zu früh sind und ich habe ja
die kommentare gehört wir sind alle froh
dass es keinen hotspot regeln gibt ich
kann nur sagen ich hätte diese regeln
einfach vier bis sechs wochen verlängert
und dann werde ich genauso entspannt in
die nächste zeit gegangen wir sind
einfach einen ticken zu früh dran mit
unseren lockerungen und nicht generell
ist das problem und was das
infektionsschutzgesetz nochmal diese
hotspot redouane geht das wollte ich
gerne auch nochmal aufgreifen sie ist
genauso wir reagieren wenn wir diese
maßnahme um sie sie wollen mit der
feststellung die krankenhäuser sind
überlastet viel zu spät auf einen
ausbruchsgeschehen wenn das ganze
festgestellt wird dass die krankenhäuser
über laufen dann ist das
infektionsgeschehen schon längst voll im
gange und ergreifen diese regelungen
viel zu spät und da ich denke da hat man
auch handwerklich nicht gut gearbeitet
interessant ist aber tatsächlich das in
vielen nachbarländern oder in ländern
nach deutschland in europa nicht
unbedingt nur in den nachbarländern dass
dort tatsächlich schon vor längerer zeit
gelockert wurde und wir haben auch einen
beitrag dazu mit dem beispiel spanien
von hannah metzger und schon zusammen
rein
in vielen europäischen ländern werden
die regeln zur quarantäne pflicht neu
festgelegt wie in spanien dort wird eine
corona infektion künftig fast nur noch
wie eine normale krankheit behandelt
ähnlich einer grippe für corona
infizierte die keine oder nur leichte
krankheitszeichen aufweisen gilt keine
quarantäne pflicht mehr testen und in
häusliche isolation begeben müssen sich
nur noch gefährdete personen wie zum
beispiel menschen über 60 eine masken
pflicht in geschlossenen räumen besteht
aber weiterhin spanien wurde zu beginn
der pandemie besonders hart getroffen
inzwischen ist die lage aber entspannt
die sieben tage incidents liegt bei
277,1 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohnern dahingegen meldete das robert
koch institut in deutschland
1663 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohnern auch die impfquote ist in
spanien höher als in deutschland
das ist natürlich für manche auch nur
schwer nachzuvollziehen also wir haben
die schlechteren zahlen die schlechtere
impfquote und das wundert vielleicht
dann auch nicht dass die menschen nicht
mehr so recht wissen wie sie das ganze
eigentlich einschätzen sollen die
aktuelle corona anlage hersteller wie
würden sie das einschätzen dass da die
europäischen kolleginnen und kollegen da
vielleicht ganz anders argumentieren und
ja ganz andere entscheidungen treffen
und ja ja ja
ich meine das ist natürlich klar wir
haben jetzt den beitrag aus spanien
gehört ich habe eine höhere impfquote
ich habe eine deutlich niedrigere
instanz und ich sagte ja auch eben schon
ich bin auch nicht kein gegner von
lockerung im gegenteil ich freue mich
genauso wenn er wieder viel mehr
normalität in unseren alltag rein
bekommen aber es muss der richtige
zeitpunkt zahlen ich glaube das ist das
entscheidende ich kann nicht in einer
ansteigenden welle mit mit der
befürchtung dass dpa zwei variante da
noch mehr schaden anrichtet ganz
entspannt zu tun als kann ich locker das
kann ich machen wenn meine incidents
deutlich runter ist oder meine impfquote
höher ist und dementsprechend ist es
auch schwierig die länder miteinander zu
vergleichen die sind in ganz anderen
phasen der der infektion der der der
pandemie und haben ganz andere
impfquoten spanien ist deutlich wärmer
da ist sicherlich jetzt schon viel mehr
aktivität im freien somit das risiko in
den innenräumen sich anzustecken
deutlich reduziert und das das haben wir
hier noch nicht und was ist zum beispiel
ein beispiel für mich ist dass man auch
dinge wieder korrigieren kann österreich
war ja auch sehr freizügig mit der
rückführung von maßnahmen hat die masken
pflicht im inneren uhr wieder eingeführt
auch das zeigt ja dass man letztendlich
da der meinung ist vielleicht manche
schritte zu früh getan zu haben
wir sehen auch es gibt also wirklich
diese zum einen zum anderen stimmung bei
uns im stream till dorfschmied schreibt
wir beenden jetzt die maßnahmen um sie
im herbst wieder einzuführen der
pandemie modus muss komplett und
dauerhaft enden grippe ist auch in dem
ich so müssen wir es behandeln die
gegenstimme dazu evi weber schreibt
mecklenburg vorpommern vorpommern
handelt richtig masken abstand und
impfen sind weiterhin wichtige tools
also ihr seid da natürlich auch am
diskutieren in unserem stream und
schauen jetzt aber auch noch mal konkret
auf das was jetzt also kommt zum
wochenende zum montag dann natürlich
spätestens was also passiert ist so dass
eben das tragen von masken
wegfällt in vielen bundesländern und nur
noch in ausnahmefällen die besonderen
hotspots angeordnet werden können
christian du hast es vorhin angesprochen
es gibt aber da auch ein bisschen die
befürchtung dass natürlich auch klagen
kommen könnten jetzt gegen mecklenburg
vorpommern und hamburg im zweifel die ja
gesagt haben sie möchten also die
hotspot regelung jetzt weiter anwenden
wie wahrscheinlich sind solche klagen
und könnte so was dann also auch wieder
kassiert werden die klagen sind auf
jeden fall wahrscheinlich die erste ist
auch schon angekündigt worden von der
fdp und von der afg in hamburg solche
klagen damit muss man allgemein glaube
ich einfach rechnen wie aussichtsreich
allerdings sind das ist wirklich schwer
vorherzusagen das werden die gerichte
dann zu gegebener zeit entscheiden
vermutlich schon relativ bald weil das
ganze als bedürftig ist aber dass es
solche klagen gibt das haben wir während
der kroner pandemie ja zur genüge
gesehen also es gibt glaube ich keine
maßnahme gegen die nicht geklagt wurde
und was natürlich auch noch so ein punkt
das sind die zugangsregeln wie 2g oder
3g die dann im restaurant geschichte
sein könnten herr stürmer wie finden sie
das also die ganze zeit haben wir
natürlich darauf gepocht und immer
wieder hieß es impfen impfen und jetzt
fällt das ganze b ist das für sie und
wie schätzen sie das ein
ich glaube ich kann mit mit dem wegfall
dieser regelungen noch erleben als mit
dem wegfall der masken pflicht weil
tatsächlich durch omikron noch mal
erfahren mussten dass eben 2g und 3g
nicht mehr in der form zumindest was das
impfen das boostern angeht diese schärfe
hat wie noch bei den alten varianten und
dementsprechend ist das für mich nicht
ganz so tragisch aber spätestens wenn
man angepassten impfstoff wieder
bekommen werden da die karten neu
gemischt und dann hätte solche optionen
auch wieder eine ganz andere wirkung und
insofern sind das natürlich mögliche
maßnahmen die wir für den herbst und
winter wieder brauchen könnten
da muss man einfach abwarten wie sich
die situation entwickelt und ich habe ja
gerade die kritik gehört von aus dem
publikum dass man sagt ja wir müssen
jetzt endlich mit dieser virus leben
lernen würde ich auch gerne und ich sehe
aber nur das problem dass wir ein
bisschen hausaufgaben dafür machen
müssen und da muss man ganz klar sagen
wenn wir jetzt nicht im sommer genau
definieren wie es wie es weitergeht dass
wir einfach lernen wie sich dieses virus
im sommer weiterentwickelt ob neue
variante kommt ob die delta vita kommt
wie wir mit dem impfen weiter vorgehen
dann wärmer im herbst und winter wieder
in andere probleme rutschen können und
spätestens wenn dann eine variante kommt
die wieder klinisch mehr durch schlägt
dann sind wir wieder mittendrin im
geschehen und deswegen sollte man nicht
zu leichtfertig meinen das ist wie eine
influenza zu behandeln haken dran wir
kennen das virus erst zwei jahre da sind
noch einige überraschungen die wir noch
nicht kennen und ich bin eher der
vorsichtige mensch ich weiß das passt
vielen nicht unbedingt die sind etwas
etwas riskanter in ihrem alltag aber ich
sehe es einfach so dass wir da noch ein
bisschen zu warten zu halten
christian an dich dann noch mal die
frage was aber wenn jetzt
restaurantbetreiber betreiberinnen dann
aber trotzdem vielleicht darauf bestehen
wollen und sagen wollen ich möchte aber
hier den impfnachweis sehen ist das
rechtens also restaurant betreiberinnen
betreiber zum beispiel die haben das so
genannte aus recht das heißt sie können
selbst regeln nach welchen
nach welchem verfahren sie ihre gäste
bewirten wollen und welche einlass
regeln sie zum beispiel machen also in
der massen pflicht in einem restaurant
das ist auch nach dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz problemlos
durchsetzbare ja
und dann vielleicht herrscht immer zum
schluss auch noch mal weil gerade die
massen pflicht das wird ja immer mehr
diskutiert vielleicht auch die frage
dann noch mal an sie was wenn keine
masken mehr getragen werden was sind
denn die risiken die sie da sehen
gut zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist es so
dass wir dann einfach im innenraum
deutlich häufiger übertragung sehen
werden das mag für viele gar nicht so
schlimm sein die schütteln das dann ab
nach ein paar tagen krank zu hause aber
wir haben ja eben noch menschen unter
uns die
möglicherweise ein höheres risiko haben
schwerere verläufe zu bekommen wir haben
menschen unter uns die sich überhaupt
nicht impfen lassen können weil sie
aufgrund ihrer ihrer vorerkrankungen
dass es nicht möglich ist die lassen wir
natürlich komplett im regen stehen wir
lassen unsere kinder unter fünf jahren
komplett im regen stehen die sich im
prinzip nur dadurch schützen können vor
der infektion dass wir eben um sie herum
mit den masken innenraum alles mögliche
tun die infektion zu vermeiden auch da
kommt wird die kritiker sagen ja die
kinder werden ja nicht schwer krank
stimmt aber was weiß ich dann über folge
infektion was weiß ich über longo witt
wir gehen bis jetzt davon aus dass wir
mit zehn bis 15 prozent rechnen müssen
mit den alten varianten das sind nicht
alles schwere fälle aber ich kann das
nicht ausschließen so lange ich das
nicht sicher weiß dass diese variante
die wir jetzt haben wirklich komplett
harmlos ist dass es nichts anderes ist
als ein viraler schnupfen so lange bin
ich der meinung dass wir alles tun
sollten um alle teile der bevölkerung
wirklich adäquat zu schützen und das
kann ich mit der maske im innenraum sehr
sehr effizient tun
sagt martin stürmer der virologe vielen
dank und auch vielen dank an dicht
christian decker unser rechtsexperte
dass sie ihr beide hier die fragen
beantwortet habt und uns ein bisschen
mehr klarheit gegeben habt so gerne
und danke natürlich auch an euch für die
fragen für die kommentare und dass er
mitgemacht habt und seit gerne in den
nächsten tagen wieder bei uns dabei bis
dahin danke tschüss